this is the Dave Ramsey show we're
talking with Sean in Huntsville got a
landscaping in lawn care business that's
wrapping up for summer and he's going to
close it down and get a job they're
behind on everything we've got a
thousand dollar rent nine hundred
dollars were the car payments he's
trying to figure out whether bankruptcy
or breaking leases or what's up next is
thing well that's how far we got in the
discussion is that a fair summary what
you told me so far it is okay all right
when I have an elephant sitting in front
of me I have to decide how I'm going to
eat the elephant and that's what you've
got you've got an overwhelming situation
it's a chance huge it's a huge huge mess
and so where do we start
and if you don't figure out where to
start you won't ever start and what we
figured out and working with these
situations and I've been right where you
are it's scariest crud how many kids
have you got three okay
how old are you 29 okay
I had two kids I was 28 when I went
bankrupt so I know right where you are
what what I would tell you is this let's
take care of first things first okay the
first thing that you have to take care
of is food right until you've taken care
of food for your family I don't care
about the other bills period I don't
care how much they gripe or how scared
you are or what's going on food is first
we got that clear right second thing is
lights and water okay okay now who's
your landlord do you have an individual
or corporate landlord it's managed by a
property manager a company
okay and they're local yes they are
okay call them set an appointment and go
sit down in front of them out not over
the phone and not by email in person and
ask for mercy to be released from the
lease instead of calling up and going I
just moved
sue me okay that doesn't work well
because they will they
oblige all right but sometimes if you
call a landlord you sit down and go hey
here's what's going on I got three kids
I'm broke I got no job
my business is closing I'm scared as I
can be I don't know if you've ever been
there
but I'm asking for mercy we've got to
move to a cheaper place how can we work
this out
I cannot stay but help me and I'll work
with you I'll help you get the house
cleaned up we'll leave it perfect or
we'll help you show it if you want to
show it or if you want to give us a
little break on the rent for a little
while till we can get back on our feet
maybe we can work it that way
I don't care but I'm just telling you
guys I this is not I can't do this and
feed my kids right because you can't on
$40,000 a year have a $1000 round
doesn't fit okay and then see what comes
with that figure it maybe they maybe
they knock it down to seven hundred for
three months till you get back on your
feet that'd be nice or maybe they'd say
okay we'll show it and when we get a
renter we'll let you a new renter we'll
let you out of the lease as a landlord I
have done that when people came in with
the right attitude but when people throw
me up a couple of middle fingers I'll
break them right okay so we don't go the
other way right right so you just got
decide on how you're going to approach
it and a hat in hand is the best way to
do it you'll get some you'll oftentimes
get some kind of mercy if you just ask
for it in your persistent now the stupid
cars are the next thing in the line and
have you figured out what they're worth
oh my cheaper one and all summer has
just been sitting in our yard um it's
worth about maybe two grand and we owe a
little bit over 5500 over there the
other one is worth about 20 and we owe
24 on it
okay and I assume your credits destroyed
yeah it is okay the 20 the one that I
was 2002 do that - um it's can't modify
that jeez okay um call them and tell
them you need to skip two payments and
they need to roll them into the balance
okay meanwhile you're going to do
everything in your power working six
jobs and going crazy man to come up with
four grand so you can get that car sold
is you don't have the ability to borrow
the money you've got to earn it and
they're not going to cut you a deal they
don't do that but they will let you sell
the car for twenty thousand and you put
four with it and pay them off and
they'll send the title to the new owner
right but we so we need that four grand
difference you follow me yep so hustle
and grind baby that's what that one's
about and then you get rid of that one
that's the one that's killing you that's
what 600 oh let's write out five yeah
okay man you got screwed on that little
car didn't you yeah it was basically I
buy here pay here place oh geez
okay um swing by there and talk to them
and see if you can write them a $500
check and they'll take the car without
it being a repo no recourse passed it I
want to settle the repo up in front if
you just hand them the keys they're
gonna sell it for a thousand bucks to
sue you for the difference I don't want
to do that okay but if they'll let you
buy you know give them a little check of
some kind and they'll take the keys and
let you go then you're out of that one
because that one's bad three hundred
bucks a month for that thing Lord man
what a mess so it let's just pretend all
that happened and you got a job I think
we made it right yeah but there's some
pretty serious moves have to be made
there we got a lease to work our way out
of we got a car to get sold and we got a
little one to turn in or get it sold one
of the two and get rid of carpets cuz
you know make car payments you had a
reasonable rent we can turn this thing
around you got other debt um yeah I mean
we've got credit cards and personal
loans okay
how much um credit cards we've got about
six thousand dollars and about four
thousand and personal loans okay you're
not paying any of those right now
yeah well we not until you get these
other things done right they just sit
and they're gonna scream and flop in the
floor and foam at the mouth and all that
stuff just hang up on them you just
can't pay them right now you don't have
any money you got to feed your kids you
got a place to live
keep the lights on you this
transportation mess straightened out oh
wait a minute you could sell your
equipment at the end of season and that
will help you move one of those cars - I
left that out of the equation that's as
you said that stuff will bring a
thousand bucks or so right yeah probably
with everything I have
okay that's fine yeah I mean if you
scrape together the other three then
that gets you out that big car mess
right yeah yeah and turns it around so
you can make it I think you make the
corner here and I you know you're not
bankrupt yet you're just scared
and you don't know you didn't know what
to put first it may if you know it's
possible that you get forced into a
bankruptcy later because they take these
cars and the Landlord ends up suing you
you know if this gets really really dark
you might get forced into it but that's
a year from now that's not now it's at
least a year okay and in the meantime
I'm going to walk with you and we're
going to help you and I think you can
turn this around but it's all about the
income that you make as to how quick you
can turn it around right right and
that's not biggest problem so far and
are stupid from before yeah yeah well
the stupid cars Oh Lord they're awful
but but your income turns the situation
you know and so the restaurant
management job and working side jobs and
you know anything you can get doing
anything because a thousand bucks a
month added to whatever formula you've
got as a part-time gig changes this
stuff fast I mean because I mean if we
went ten thousand dollars to throw with
this it straightens the whole mess up
fast
yeah and so you're that close to getting
out of this mess and not but you've just
got to get it before they start taking
stuff and before you know you get shut
down but here's what happens emotionally
do you get scared and you get to
fighting with your spouse and everything
else and you might kill each other
that's what Sharon and I did anyway I
don't know about y'all but um you know
and and so you guys got to hold each
other in a tight hug not not the other
way around in the middle of this and so
don't let this stuff take your marriage
and make sure you're in a good Church
and take care of food
in light second and shelter is third if
you got food lights and shelter you can
make it you can make it around the
corner you know and the rest this crap
is a Monopoly game that you're losing
but you may be able to turn it around
you pass go you hit free parking you
know and yeah that kind of thing so you
hold on I'm going to put you in
Financial Peace University as my guest
I'm going to pay for it so that you and
your wife can get your arms around this
and get you some help as you walk
through this you're not bankrupt you're
going to make it you just got to get
your income rolling and you got to take
some very proactive steps this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys Rachael Cruz
here hope you enjoyed that video from
the Dave Ramsey show if you want to
watch another great video check out my
video three things you should consider
renting right over here or click the
link in the description below